so now let's jump straight in um i'm
we're going to get started with a
a fireside chat with uh johannes gerke
and the managing director of microsoft's
research at redmond
um before that he was leading
architecture and machine learning for
ic3 which is the intelligent
communications and conversations cloud
which powers microsoft teams before that
he was a professor at cornell for many
years
and before that he was completing his
phd at university of wisconsin
which i actually just recently learned
and is really cool because that's where
i did my phd
so go badgers uh johannes's main
research interests are in database
systems distributed systems
and machine learning he's received a
litany of awards over the years
including the
national science foundation career award
an arthur p sloan fellowship
a humboldt research award an ieee
computer
society technical achievement award
among others
and i'm really excited for him to be
with us today for this fireside chat
johannes welcome uh thank you sean um
so it's great to be here and i just
wanted to welcome you to this
third ai breakthrough event it's
really unfortunate that we cannot see
each other in person but i'm looking
forward to engaging with you and smaller
groups throughout the day
i mean i also wanted to to thank uh
daniel and sean for
and the team for organizing the event um
so i wanted to give you a little bit of
background
before going into the fireside chat
and i wanted to actually step back and
look at microsoft's mission
because um this is actually a mission
that i fully subscribe to
and it's clearly a mission where that's
very actionable
so first of all there's there's a focus
on innovation right we believe that
technology should be a force for the
good and that a lot of meaningful
innovation
can contribute to making the world
better and small in big ways and with
microsoft research of course playing a
really big role
there's a huge focus in the values of
the company on diversity and inclusion
the the mission by itself is very
inclusive empower every person every
organization on the planet to achieve
more
so this means that we expect all of us
depending
independent of what our role is what our
level is what our function is whether
msr or not to really play an active role
in creating an environment where
everybody is excited to bring
everything of what they are and who they
are to do the best work
um another focus that you may have seen
in the press
a lot recently about microsoft that i'm
really personally excited about is also
is social responsibility
so this actually there's a variety of
programs at microsoft that we as
microsoft employees and of course
at msr can contribute and engage in and
play as
a crucial role for example one of them
is sustainability
where over the last year you know
microsoft has committed to becoming
carbon negative you probably heard about
this it's really
is becoming a zero waste company that is
building
a new big compute platform to
look at the earth's natural system and
now actually the pledge that came out
yesterday was to become
water positive by 2030 um and
that means that we replenish more water
than we'll use
and i think it's just these kind of
commitments that for me at least put the
mission into action
there's of course also a big commitment
to accessibility
right that especially for the tools and
everything that we're building we focus
on also
people with impairments to vision
hearing tools for learn
has eight labs over a thousand
scientists you know a lot of
really famous people here and um it
really spans now across the world
so it's you know we're clearly here in
research at redmond
um but we have um three other labs
across the us
and then of course a lab in cambridge
and then labs in beijing shanghai
and india and there are you know each
lab
each lab sort of has its own culture and
and its own focus
but there is a lot of collaboration
across the labs
um there are projects that span redmond
and cambridge and beijing
and then it's often hard to actually
find a time zone where everybody can
make it
for example this week there's a workshop
happening across
ai for software engineering that i'm a
part of and
actually the workshop happens one day
early in the morning
and the next day late in the evening to
sort of be an equal opportunity offender
for everybody
and basically what these these labs
allow us to basically look at a
diversity of different approaches
in the frame of our mission but then
really connect across the company and
especially since
all of our development is not only local
here in redmond but it's also spread
across the world
every lab can also engage with local
product groups to have even closer
connections
last i want to say a little bit about
our research styles
because they go all the way from purely
curiosity driven research to more
mission
driven research so in curator
curiosity driven research we really have
it's called sometimes also horizon three
is a really long term research
it's purely based on curiosity of an
individual researcher
so we look into the future we envision
what the future could be
we prototype interesting cool things
like in our hci team there's really
amazing work going on
we try to solve the really hardest
problems and sometimes don't make
progress for years at a time but then
come up with breakthrough
and this is really what the company has
funded us for the company wants us to
preserve the future for microsoft
and therefore look ahead but then some
of these projects they also move ahead
and you know we solve some important
problem we actually make a technology
breakthrough
and then actually they lead to very
short-term
midterm immediate tangible really high
impact on our business and that's
also what excites me i made um i can
talk a bit more about this later on but
i made a detour where i started out as
professor for a while
and then i was actually in a product
team for seven years and now i came back
to research and it's really interesting
to look at the interplay between
research and product
and that's one of the things that
microsoft is is really strong at and
we're really proud of the great
collaboration
between msr and our product teams
um so with that short framing i'm really
excited that
um to looking forward to interacting
with you and
um i'm looking forward to the fireside
chat now
great thank you sean thank you johannes
uh yeah so
let's let's uh let's get into the
fireside chat portion so
so you already kind of hinted about this
a little bit um in your
your remarks just now but i was
wondering if you could start a little
bit by telling us
kind of about yourself and about your
personal journey through
academia through industry you kind of
have a unique
journey i think um that's kind of very
msr in a way being academic and an
industry
um but i'm curious kind of how did you
get into research originally
um and kind of how did you end up where
you are now as as managing director of
research at redmond today
yeah it's um um so i was always as
a child i was always fascinated by
technology and computers i was always a
tinkerer
i loved to program already in middle and
high school
and then you know computer science was a
was a natural way
um or the natural subject for me as a
student i got early on exposed
to research in germany you can do you
can sort of go into a research group and
they pay to do some programming
and there's actually a database group in
germany
and that's where i sort of learned to
love the problems and the database
systems area where
you have this really beautiful often
high level declarative language
and that only says what you want but not
how it's actually being computed and
that then translates down through a
query optimizer and then very efficient
query processing technologies
to really scale out to you know hundreds
of nodes and in a way for a long time
i would say that sql is probably the you
know most successful parallel
programming language because you
actually completely isolated from all
the parallelism that that's happening
um and um then through a detour i ended
up as an exchange student in the u.s
and got stuck here um and i ended up in
wisconsin where i did my phd
my advisor interestingly is now also
here at microsoft he is the cto of data
ragu ramakrishnan here
but then i went to academia and i
was really lucky to get a job at cornell
and cornell was just
really a fantastic place it's a very
collaborative department i had
i really had the privilege of working
with a fantastic group of phd students
um
i over time there i was there for close
to 15 years and i and i graduated 25 phd
students and worked with six postdocs it
was just a really
amazing group that we had um they are
both not only in the database
area but across the whole um faculty
i i don't know it's only it would be
live i would ask were there any
condolence here in the audience um
but um yeah we have some i think yep
and at cornell um what i worked on was
a lot of core database problems but um
less in the core of database systems but
more applying database ideas to other
problems for example i started to work
out in sensor networks
where we thought of the distributed
sensors
in a large scale sensor network as mini
database systems that each will
hold a table with a sensor readings and
then we looked at query processing
techniques that spanned ad hoc
networking and query processing
i worked on data stream processing i
worked on a lot of
scalable data stream algorithms and then
i also worked on data privacy
which actually came from an interesting
connection
with the government where after 9 11 and
we were selected to
look at technologies that could help the
government to
integrate across different government
agencies with a very strong interest of
actually preserving privacy
um and so then i discovered differential
privacy which was of course your pioneer
at msr by cynthia dwork
and my group actually developed the very
first public data set together with a
census bureau
this is called on the map and this is
actually the very first public data set
i was ever published that had
formal privacy guarantees with it it
actually had a version of epson delta
differential privacy and in between
i was part of a startup it's a norwegian
startup it called fast search and
transfer some colleagues
introduced me to it i was chief
scientist at this company
and the company was acquired in 2008 by
microsoft
so it was actually the first time i
actually got a microsoft blue badge
which is sort of the
badge for a full-time employee but then
i went back to cornell
and then in about you know 2013
um you know some of our friend my
friends in that company and and we had
another idea
and the idea was that first the company
was about enterprise search
an enterprise search in a way was always
much worse than internet search
and the reason for that was that in the
internet we're signal rich because
the world's population is going after
the same corpus of data
and in addition the corpus is also very
rich in that we have you know
reputation of sites we have links
between sites and you know of course now
we have many other signals
in the enterprise traditionally
enterprise search is signal poor
enterprises have vast collections of
documents
but very few employees there are very
few searches within a company
so the relevance of enterprise search
was always a problem
um but now as office 365 moved into the
cloud and that sort of was happening in
a few years before that
suddenly even enterprises or enterprise
search has become signal rich
for example right now sean you know the
two of us are here in the same meeting
this actually now creates an edge
between the two of us and so therefore
the documents that i've created up may
be a little bit more relevant for you
so what we built is a data asset that we
call the office graph at that point in
time and it basically took all of the
signals
that office 365 created and first of all
made them available
to individual tenants through an api but
then also used them to make
enterprise search and a bunch of other
applications we built an application
called delve
it's more like a relevance feed for you
and made all of these much better
and at that point in time then i was
thinking you know should i return to
cornell or stay here and
microsoft was just such an exciting
place in terms of data
in terms of collaboration in just in
terms of scale
and so at that point in time with a
heavy heart i decided to leave cornell
and stay here at microsoft
um then i worked on microsoft teams
and i was the chief architect of the
back end and i was leading ai for teams
for
for a while um for example we rebuilt um
large parts of the infrastructure with
the modern arjun architecture and that
was really a lot of fun
and then when about four years um you
know i was presented with the
opportunity of what that would be
you know interest in coming back to msr
i didn't think twice
and i was just really excited about
being here and it's been
really a privilege to work with
everybody here msr is just a fantastic
place
it's it's a place where we have
ring-fenced resources to look
you know really at the future of the
company and preserve the future of the
company but really also society
and so i'm really excited both by you
know microsoft's mission how it applies
to msr
but also in general how you know
microsoft research works
as an entity it's great well it's good
and it's so great to have you here at
msr these days
um i'm curious so your background
started
mostly in databases distributed systems
and that's kind of
you know you're an expert and one of the
world's foremost experts in those areas
and it seems like probably kind of
machine learning
and ai sort of crept in to the work and
became more
maybe a little bit more important over
the years i'm curious like how did
how did machine learning sort of start
to enter the equation for you and
and ai more broadly yeah so my
my thesis most interesting in what's
called data mining
and so this was basically taking some
machine learning algorithms and really
scaling them up to very large data sets
and i was always interested in the
interplay of data and statistics
now here at microsoft i just saw the
power of machine learning in many real
world applications
i mean if you look at teams many of you
may have used background blur
we're in the process of rolling out
noise suppression
you know i talked already about our
strategy of taking the media stack of
teams and replacing it with machine
learning components
so there's basically just the the power
of machine learning the power of ai
in real applications especially right
now where you can take
individual components and take them
and replace them with ai is just really
powerful and just gives us much better
performance than human written rules
this is actually happening for example
also in database systems interestingly
there is now a really interesting set of
research that looks at
replacing the control plane of database
systems with machine learning
so if you think about database systems
again there's sort of a data plane and a
control plane the data plane is
basically
we have the data plane we have the query
plan and we let it run
the control plane is about you know
here's the sql
and what is the actual query plan that
we're using to execute it
and that was traditionally done through
a combination of you know dynamic
programming and various search
strategies that people have tried out
and
now the search strategies are happening
for example through deep reinforcement
learning
where over time you both discover the
statistics that you need to
decide on the best plan as well as you
know what
what parts of the planned search space
you should explore and so that's really
exciting i think more and more parts of
a database system that are sort of more
on the control plane
will be replaced with ai as well
interesting interesting
cool well so so the name of the event is
is ai breakthroughs
um and so i was kind of curious to to
learn about what you
think about in terms of what are the
most important exciting
you know moon shots for research in the
aisle they're often called moon shots i
mean i'm also kind of curious how do you
even think about moon shots in general
at msr is that just
a metaphor for doing ambitious research
um i'm curious what you think about like
what are the most important and exciting
breakthroughs or moonshots and and how
they might have a positive impact on
people on society
uh and on the planet well that's that's
a big question um so let me let me take
it sort of piece by piece
so um i think um
you know first of all i'm not an expert
in the eye so what i'm going to tell you
but but i think what i what i've seen a
lot is what ai can do
and so i think even one exciting
moonshot is
to take ai and make it really work for
some
high value real-life scenarios um
you know for example if you look there's
huge societal benefit if you look at
healthcare
education transportation productivity
just to name a few for example
productivity you could imagine that you
know i don't program
alone but i have an ai peer programmer
you could imagine that i don't
write my document alone but i have a
coach
an ai coach it's like the powerpoint
presenter coach that we currently have
that gives you feedback on your
presentation and of course these are
specialized examples but i think
there's very often a big gap between the
eye that's being or the
machine learning that's been published
in papers and that's applied to very
specific scenarios than to actually make
it work in practice
um and so you know is that a big
moonshot maybe not but i think it
actually is something that would make a
really big difference
another moonshot i think maybe to look
at and to understand how
machines and humans can deeply
collaborate
you know you saw that already a little
bit in the examples that i had before
where many applications of ai have been
really trying to replace a full human so
maybe in self-driving cars or
maybe really relieve humans of
microtasks but i don't have to compose a
full world anymore
in a sprint reply to my email because
you know a model predicts what i'm going
to say anyway
but in general i think there are a lot
of really interesting challenges as
people and ai collaborate um
you know again let's go back to the
healthcare scenario one example is
transfer of control again in the email
scenario it's super easy
but assume we do this in an education
scenario right what does the student do
and what is the
ideals that the student will actually
learn something and doesn't only give
the ai
enough hints how do you do this in a
healthcare scenario what does the doctor
do and what does the ai do
how does the doctor transfer you know
control to in the eye and also back um
is it more like a teacher or student or
is it on equal footing with ai actually
being creative
and i think this ultimate means that we
need models to explain
that they're making certain choices and
we you know humans can understand the
inference of the next steps
um another good example of this
collaboration is also cognitive tasks
right so i think cognitive psychologists
have worked for a long time
on you know characterization of the
human mind
um and ai could help us to augment human
cognition
by understanding human weaknesses you
know in health and illnesses
and mental illnesses for example you
know they could remind me of things that
i like to forget
make better decisions or have a better
focus of attention
you know i don't have to meditate
anymore every morning but maybe the eye
helped me to automatically stay focused
and then there are lots of course
interesting technical problems i'm sort
of talking more application areas
clearly in training and inference my
brains are supposed to be
you know maybe order 10 to the 5 more
energy efficient than our current
models you know gbt3 is is really big
and and really interesting but it's also
so expensive that it's hard to deploy
for any real applications
so how do we create models
and training and you know so training an
inference
that we can actually afford and that we
can deploy at a wide scale
and this then also goes all the way to
theorem algorithms right i
talked about the problem of finding new
ways of reducing
energy scaling up to the you know the
next data center i mean
a high level calculation would be a data
center maybe has 60 megawatts
let's assume a neural processing unit
will take 60 watts
well then maybe in the next generation
data center i'll have order 10 to the
six
npus or 10 to the five
how do i scale you know my training up
to
that level of of npus and dual presence
and units
so these are all interesting questions
um that i think are
you know moonshots uh for ai and for ai
applications
yeah and for for all of those
breakthroughs and and all and other
areas like
i mean it seems to me that msr is a
pretty special place to be working
towards these i mean
that that's that's why i'm i'm here and
i'm curious what you think about what
makes msr that kind of special place and
particularly thinking about
all of the opportunities internally with
other groups at microsoft product teams
but also externally
with partnerships uh universities and
other institutions
um to kind of make progress together
towards these these big achievements
yeah so it's a great question first of
all um
i see msr as sort of a huge playground
for
creativity and freedom and impact um
you know if you know i'd really had the
privilege for the last three months of
really going on a learning tour
of learning about all the projects i
mean sean you you know i learned so much
about your
research i'm sorry from you that's
really exciting
um so so first of all i think it's
really an amazing place if you want to
be a creative researcher
um i think and that coupled with the
mission of the company and the ethics of
the company
and then also really the resources and
the partnerships that we have across the
company um
again i'm coming from a product team
while i was in a product team
actually we had a research project that
was leading that was led across
product and across microsoft you know
research at redmond across
msr a and msri and some of that was more
short term and then some of that was
really very very long-term research
and so i think just being able to
partner with product teams where
suddenly you have an idea and then you
see it grow
and have an impact on you know millions
and millions of users right i mean the
work in teams that we did
is now you know impacting everybody both
from
you know small people to big people in
terms of um you know education
health care mobility work from home and
everywhere
so i think having that kind of impact
and having that kind of possibility at
microsoft
just makes it a very special place and
maybe the last thing is
so wherever i have worked one thing
i really cared a lot about is that you
know are they actually
um good people there and and people that
i would get along with
and that's the other thing that i felt
about msr is that we just have a
really fantastic set of people that are
collaborative and open
and really interesting in your ideas
yeah that's great yeah really good
people here
um i wanted to get to one of the
questions from the q
a we have about five minutes left um
because it's i think it's a really good
question about
kind of advice so they're asking about
it do you have any tips for those
deciding between careers in industry
versus academia
and a related question kind of how
difficult is it to switch from one to
the other
at a later point in time right
now it's a great question um
industry and academia i think is is
quite different
um so if you go to academia
basically you are on your own um so you
think of yourself as the ceo of
a small company so i remember when i
when i joined cornell
and i was sort of asking around what do
you need to get tenure here
and they said well to get 10 you need to
be famous do you have to write a certain
number of papers no
you have to get a certain amount of
grants no just do whatever is necessary
to create the most
impact right and so they gave me a desk
and a little bit of money and said good
luck with that
right um and i think that's an amazing
opportunity right i mean so if you have
that level of entrepreneurship if you
have that level of ideas
also i think that's the most important
thing and if you feel like you have
all the independent ideas that you want
to do this um
academia is a great place especially um
you know you have
amazing students that you can work with
so
you know i can only say positive things
about academia
i think here at microsoft the place is a
little bit different in that you could
do exactly the same thing
but you also have and by the way we
value that a lot
but you also have the opportunity to
join other projects
and to do something much bigger than you
could do with a few graduate students
and to partner with product teams and to
learn about problems that
people care about because a lot of the
product teams as well as a lot of people
in msr
they're very deep knowledge of the
industry and where
industry is going and therefore working
on problems that are not only
technically interesting
but where there's also possibility of
them actually shipping them and seeing
them in a product and then in the way
really touching them
that is also really exciting and
can be very satisfying so i think both
of them
are really good places we see more and
more people moving back and forth
um so we people we see people from you
know msr they've been here for some
years they moved back to academia
and we've seen people who come from
academia you know like myself
and go to industry so i think in both
cases um there is movement
across here at msr clearly we are
you know open clearly to publication
um then it's strongly encouraged and our
people publish in the top conferences
get pissed paper awards and
talk about all the great work that's
going on here um but in addition i think
the other point of impact that we can
make here is that we can
charge the product groups and therefore
indirectly touch the
you know hundreds of millions of
customers that microsoft has all across
the world
great um and i wanted to ask one more
question and i kind of
there was one more question in the q a
that kind of merges this one with one of
mine
thinking kind of zooming in like on on a
successful project at msr
the components that make a successful
project obviously there's
no one answer for that there are
projects at many different scales
um but i'm wondering how how you view
kind of
not only what are the components of a
successful successful project but
someone asked
um sort of how do research projects
typically get initiated
at msr are they kind of team is it a
team based process
or do individual researchers have the
freedom to initiate their own projects
yeah so so the answer is all of the
above so first of all individual
researchers have
complete freedom to initiate their own
projects
um in addition sometimes product groups
come with us with some crazy ideas and
we say hey maybe this is not the really
the right idea but we could do
this other thing and it becomes a great
partnership there's actually a lot of
discussions about
what the future could look like um
within msr here and where we make maybe
certain bets
um what is the future data center going
to look like what's the future
of you know the ai infrastructure going
to look like what are the future really
high impact applications that we could
have
and then we could try and then we try to
team up across
different teams at microsoft research to
to really make something work
um some of the most impact projects that
we have
they're not only in database systems but
they're in database systems and involve
a bunch of people from machine learning
they're not only in systems but this
involves systems and machine learning
they're not only in hci but they work
hci and machine learning
so i think especially this
cross-connection is something that i
think we at microsoft research are
especially good at
and then of course there's the other you
know unfair advantage that we have at
microsoft
we have a ton of data we have um you
know all the product groups we have a
huge amount of compute available to us
so i think these other structural
advantages um
are also things that are there in our
availability to use
great well i think that's that's a
perfect place to
to leave it so uh thank you so much
johannes for
for being with us this morning thank you
thanks for limitation